[Música]
ucrania está dispuesta a negociar con
rusia según dijo el presidente de
volodymyr energy por su parte del
mandatario ruso vladimir putin insiste
en que occidente es el más afectado con
las sanciones económicas que le han
impuesto a su país mientras los misiles
rusos siguen golpeando a civiles tenemos
reportes desde jarc y
eeuu se convirtió en el primer país del
mundo de superar el millón de muertos
por kobe 19 el congreso y el presidente
joe biden le rindieron un homenaje a las
víctimas el mandatario pidió mejorar las
cadenas de suministro de vacunas para
prevenir futuras pandemias
en argentina las marchas de la llamada
unidad piquetera se repitieron en la
capital por tercera vez exigen una
acción urgente del gobierno ante la
crisis económica especialmente ahora que
la inflación subió al 58 por ciento
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
gusto acompañarlos y empezamos en
ucrania porque el presidente boludo mil
selenski indicó que está dispuesto a
negociar con su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin pero sin ultimátum insistió en el
intercambio del que ha hablado quiere
para sacar a militares atrapados en la
acería de soft al mariupol y agregó que
suiza y turquía son parte de las
negociaciones por su lado el presidente
ruso vladimir putin volvió a afirmar que
occidente es el más afectado por las
sanciones económicas que han impuesto
contra rusia y como ejemplo citó el
incremento de la inflación en europa sin
stock
es obvio que debido a las leyes
económicas objetivas al continuar con la
obsesión de las sanciones
inevitablemente lleva a consecuencias
complejas y difíciles de revertir para
la unión europea y sus ciudadanos
soy un switch grecia rusia se las
arregla con confianza frente a los
desafíos externos gracias tanto a la
política macroeconómica responsable de
los últimos años como a las decisiones
sistemáticas para fortalecer la
soberanía económica tecnológica y la
seguridad alimentaria y presión
impuestos miles de personas han muerto
en ucrania a causa de la guerra la gran
mayoría de las víctimas fueron por
ataques con misiles artillería
proyectiles o ataques aéreos en zonas
residenciales y los ataques contra
objetivos civiles todavía se están
documentando nuestras enviados
especiales leticia álvarez e irene savio
recorrieron algunos de los barrios más
afectados de jarque
olga fue testigo de cómo su barrio de
mosca le quedó arrasado
fue un proyectil y después de una bomba
que lanzaron lo destruyó todo aquí las
casas la escuela los cristales rotos los
muros rotos están mi cabaña moda
fácilmente culpa pausa desde que empezó
la invasión rusa en ucrania los
objetivos civiles han sido fuertemente
bombardeados y constantemente
bombardeados sobre todo en ciudades como
kiev mariupol o harkis donde nos
encontramos esta escuela fue bombardeada
la segunda semana del conflicto y ya lo
pueden ver hasta el autobús de
transporte de los menores está
destrozado no solo hay escuelas atacadas
también hospitales y barrios enteros de
viviendas el barrio dormitorio the
horizon fue uno de los primeros
objetivos de las tropas rusas en kharkiv
mijael lleva viviendo en el sótano del
edificio desde hace dos meses
ernesto kritz 22 proyectiles golpearon
en este edificio uno cayó en la entrada
y el otro dañó el décimo sexto piso todo
está destruido las comunicaciones
destruidas los ascensores cayeron nadie
murió aquí pero si en el edificio de la
abandoné big tony para tomm con un
poquito de
huele patrona ya mismo ha habido
repetidos ataques contra la población
civil en este barrio lo podemos ver
edificios de civiles en una zona
residencial de jarquín han sido atacados
en los primeros días de este conflicto
vladimir putin ha justificado esta
invasión como un intento de parar la
otan y asegura que sus objetivos son
militares y estratégicos pero sobre el
terreno son los civiles los que están
sufriendo las consecuencias de esta
guerra
eeuu superó el millón de muertos por
kobe 19 este jueves en el marco de la
segunda cumbre mundial sobre el
coronavirus el presidente de
estadounidense joe biden lamentó la
cifra e instó a coordinar ayuda
internacional para hacerle frente a
futuras pandemias
bandera a media asta en la casa blanca
un gesto que se repitió en los edificios
públicos de todo el país por haber
alcanzado el millón de muertos por kobe
la pandemia no ha acabado hoy alcanzamos
un trágico hito aquí en eeuu un millón
de muertes por kobe de un millón de
sillas vacías alrededor de la mesa
familiar cada una de ellas perdidas y
reemplazables insustituibles faison
los eeuu es el país del mundo con más
fallecidos por el virus y aunque lejos
quedan los días de calles vacías y
hospitales desbordados el país aún tiene
una materia pendiente poco más del 65
por ciento de la población está vacunada
por completo de sobre lesionada presión
este verano es una oportunidad para
renovar nuestros esfuerzos para seguir
acelerando con el fin de tener esta
pandemia bajo control y prevenir futuras
crisis crisis
bailén pidió al congreso estadounidense
aprobar una partida de 10 mil millones
de dólares para prevenir futuras
pandemias un esfuerzo para el que bardem
ha instado al resto de países de la
segunda sobre el 19 celebrada este
jueves alemania ha sido uno de los
primeros en responder al llamado
apoyamos su propuesta ha querido joe de
establecer un nuevo fondo en el banco
mundial para la preparación ante una
pandemia que opere en estrecha
coordinación y cooperación con la o&m s
fitch
alemania contribuirá inicialmente con 50
millones de euros china declinó la
participación en medio de la polémica
por su política de kobe cero con duras
cuarentenas frente a los nuevos rebrotes
en el país y al menos seis personas han
muerto y 350.000 han sido tratadas por
kobe 19 en corea del norte que por
primera vez admitió contagios en el país
es que toda la pandemia del gobierno
norcoreano nunca había reconocido un
caso de coronavirus ahora la agencia
estatal de noticias aseguró que casi
190.000 personas tratadas están en
cuarentena pero todavía no es claro
cuántas de ellas están contagiadas de
coronavirus dado que es probable que el
país carezca de suministros de prueba
y miles de manifestantes de
organizaciones sociales argentinas
marcharon en el centro de buenos aires
para protestar en contra de la crisis
económica la llamada unidad piquetera
exige una acción urgente del gobierno y
rechaza el ajuste que propone el fondo
monetario internacional tras la
refinanciación del crédito argentino la
convocatoria coincide con el anuncio de
que la inflación subió al 58 por ciento
juan paulo lucumí nos amplía
por trabajo por salario contra el hambre
y contra la pobreza esa fue la consigna
con la que las organizaciones de
izquierda y movimientos sociales
salieron a las calles de buenos aires en
su tercer día de protestas una jornada
en la que responsabilizaron al gobierno
de alberto fernández de la mayor subida
de precios interanual en tres décadas
según informes del instituto nacional de
estadística y censos publicados este
jueves los precios al consumidor
subieron 6% en 2022 respecto de marzo y
58 por ciento interanual acumularon un
alza de 23,1 por ciento en el primer
cuatrimestre
los argentinos piden una asistencia
social por parte del estado representada
en subsidios o inversión directa que
ayuda a compensar la elevada inflación y
consideran que es difícil cumplir esas
demandas tras la aprobación del acuerdo
de financiación de la deuda argentina
con el fmi en la que se pactó una
reducción del gasto fiscal aunque el
gobierno aprobó este jueves bonos de 150
dólares para más de 7 millones de
trabajadores informales el problema del
salario afecta además a la economía y el
consumo y después está la situación
social gravísima con la inflación y con
los programas sociales muy por debajo de
la canasta mínima elemental
y es que aparte del significativo
aumento de precios en restaurantes
recreación medicamentos alquiler de
vivienda y compra de vehículos el precio
de los alimentos acumuló un alza del 28
por ciento en los primeros 4 meses de
este año los más afectados son los
productos básicos de la canasta familiar
como el aceite el pan las carnes y los
derivados de los lácteos según el más
reciente informe del indec argentina
percibe una pobreza por encima del 37%
la cifra del desempleo desde al menos un
7% y expertos esperan que la inflación
pueda rondar el 60 por ciento anual en
el 2022
por primera vez desde que chile volvió a
la democracia una periodista fue
asesinada francisca sandoval reportera
del canal 3 la victoria falleció tras
recibir un disparo en la cabeza el
pasado primero de mayo mientras
informaba sobre una manifestación del
día del trabajo las primeras
investigaciones señalan que los
responsables estarían vinculados a
grupos delincuenciales en zonas de
santiago los cuerpos de seguridad
detuvieron a un hombre que parece que
permanece en prisión preventiva el
jueves hubo una manifestación en la
conocida como plaza italia para exigir
justicia
así nos despedimos ustedes sigan con la
programación de france 24
[Música]